hey guys i'm ryan right i'm jerry just
found out that we film the whole video
and and we weren't actually what we
didn't from a home in yeah we we thought
we were filming a whole video so we
moved on to the next one
the babadook the babba dude so we're
gonna talk about we're gonna watch today
not Marmaduke no the Baba Baba Dook
babba Duke is about a boy who comes
across a book and crazy [ __ ] starts
happening oh [ __ ]
yeah man yes this one was actually
recommended to me recently really uh-huh
my my mouse I guess whoever made this
movie made another movie it's supposed
to be really good that's also been
recommended to me that I haven't seen my
boss saw this and she was like all the
moms really good so does your boss a
woman yes my boss's is she a black woman
no white woman yeah probably
dude you should hit that no no I just
said to co-workers she's married she has
a kid
we're coworkers I know but did if you
get that opportunity like Jenice if
you're watching this [ __ ] right now
I have thought about it for years right
I'm Italian man now so back off lady
Jenice hot mom
babadook it sounds friendly and funny
kind of like the Jabberwock the
Jabberwocky all right I don't know give
me the Ewoks nose or Star Wars
characters you're so stupid
let's play sister
it's just a book
did you get this here a dog
it's a different horrible but babadook
Dook
it wants to skate first then you'll see
it finished children agree or wherever
it's from this monsters penis gotta stop
you can't get rid of the babadook
is is a weird
sounds of babies you off alone I mean I
don't know about you Elle is pretty
awesome I'll see it because I have to I
feel obliged to you know it's like not
because this kind of movie reviews that
are [ __ ] awesome it's because I'll
feel like a [ __ ] if I don't go like I'm
so scared if I can sit in a seat and
look at some images for an hour and a
half
man gets on your skin it does get under
your skin into your heart into your
cerebellum high your cerebellum which is
gonna be a big system hashtag ding hey
we just lost a bunch of subscribers
because we like Dane Cook hey man my
theory is this if it makes you laugh
then who cares like you know there's a
time and place you want your
intellectual humor you know you want
your Bill Hicks and your movie CK stuff
and your George Carlin like that's
what's up I know what you mean I totally
know what you mean it's like you know
people give female activists crap but
they're like the funniest people like
exactly the same dude what are they
fighting for exact perfect analogy you
just it's exactly like oh gosh sub
Jenice yeah this movie does look
terrifying cuz anything dealing with
okay first off little boys in horror
movies are never a good thing
okay notice that it's always little boys
or teenage girl or like teenage or early
20-something girls like like little boys
are creepy or like young but you know
nubile girls are always getting
possessed like it's always those two you
don't I never hear what the mother ago I
really regret having this child Hey like
this is your fault there's gotta be at
least one moment or they feel like I
should not have had you Demian probably
oh yeah and the probably the omen are in
the good son or that shitty movie at
Robert De Niro godsend oh I can't even
hide me hide and seek another thinking
of women I mean this movie is written
and directed by a woman which I just
think it's cool cuz like why well
because I mean like they're like women
already have enough trouble in Hollywood
getting scripts made or directing you
know and in genre they're even less of
them I mean you have in horror you have
the so scoot twins who are
you have a lot of notoriety now but it's
nice to see women working in genre
movies - like which need more than like
that was why guardians the galaxy was
rad cuz like a woman wrote that movie
and this is you know unless Jennifer
Kent happens to turn out to be a dude
then this will make sense sure I mean
there is a gift from what little I can
grab from the trailer it seems like
there's a feminine perspective I mean
it's a mother and her child you know
yeah I getting tortured the way how it
should be I'm not gonna go there anymore
duh I have crossed the line with this
joke okay what I love more like this - I
love horror that that sort of takes it
back to childhood things like things you
were scared I just love that idea that
concept of like the sort of ominous
presence of this movie is a is a is a is
a is a is a is a a spooky monster from a
childhood book like I just think that's
awesome hey if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the rejects
who keep it real yeah and Jerry has a
playlist where Jerry is gonna give you
reasons it's a Jerry I think I've given
anybody a reason - Jerry give you that
it should be your rating system you
should Jer hey V I give this movie 5
Jerry yeah find me it's like a little
heads of you it's like as a weird it's
like when you're in a video game they
have little pieces of your life it's
tough yeah they're like one ups yeah
exactly
you set up a sure off this guy um he's
gone here live this guy's honor all the
time yeah he does nothing but watch the
real rejects it that's all that's all
you really need to do all you need is
the real reject honestly Youssef like
you want to shout out I'm more than
happy to give you one because you're one
of our top subscribers yeah I use that
you're usually in the top 25 Youssef
Asherah people think I don't pay
attention to that but I keep I keep a
watch on who's who staying active Ryan's
like Santa Claus in that way but within
a real reject stuff exclusive yeah
instead of coal I murder someone
important to you
oh yeah so let's see what's uh thirty
thousand - 25 I have to murder about
twenty nine thousand nine hundred
seventy five people like a little
genocide
oh just is a dark episode it's a dark
movie that's what about children and
children's monsters not like like global
atrocities not like the atrocities that
plagued mankind is a whole woman and
like the fares and abuse of women for
holding autoimmune diseases like mass
mass killing is nothing about this in
here at all anyway Yousef you're not
wearing your hat what's wrong
um I don't know I I didn't these Yousef
is here it's trying to hitch okay did
don't were that maybe you should spray
it for life max palem Bella you guys
should start a real Rejects podcast to
talk about your favorite films and why
also shout out question mark hey we've
been talking about that it's actually
good and we're planning on getting a
website going where we can start
throwing a bunch of podcasts on there to
keep a lookout for that right marketing
yeah so we just wanted to plug our
future website coming to you is gonna be
more goodies on there you know it's
gonna be free I wanted to charge $10 a
membership does it all 30,000 have you
subscribed tens tens way that would be
three hundred thousand top well ten
dollars how often or for life every week
you so $40 it's like going leaving this
friends and I was thinking we put out
one video a week max we want you to be
our first investor maximum okay column
Bella Bella Bella max I'm Bella sorry
writing me up Arctic Monkeys it was song
called Arabella so Palin Bella fits in
there it's a good song you should just
do it sorry
we're moving on Davian chester oh that's
a cool name you give me a shout-out
okay Davey Chester if you want a
shout-out here's what I'm gonna tell you
I never had sex with your mother but
okay I never did I never will so I need
to just stop emailing mean of eight
no sleep you will never stop do you
sound like a kid that would be in one of
these [ __ ] like horror movies
Davian Chester no Davey and Chester
sounds like the guy you have to call to
come fix up some like Hitman related
mess hmm
my name is David Chester what [ __ ] is
the fan and they call me know it sounds
like a 1800s kind of detective Davian
Chester actual Sons ain't no mystery I
cannot crack and I get quite tomorrow
hahaha
baby and Chester now you do one more you
a more Davian Chester
okay Davey and Chester also sounds like
an eccentric scientist and like the
Marvel Universe
oh just experimenting on something and
it went wrong and now I don't know he's
no he's oxy evil yeah
now I've got some kind of animal mode